le jeune aura conflit doit savoir tirer
à l'épée
bissonnet et pète
tiré à l'épée au pistolet il doit savoir
jouer au polo diriger un aéroplane à
la doit savoir rayonner à point de vue
créant néanmoins vu quôc ngu pointu
continuant ma chérie on aime aussi chez
un jeune homme une pointe de fougue de
briand on aime aussi chez un jeune homme
une pointe de fougue de briand c'est une
qualité française qu'il ne faut pas
laisser périr mais j'ai assez cette
comédie
j'en ai marre de ses parts a marre marre
marre marre moi je ne commence à douala
il est merveilleux cas litigieux
il est délicieux il est agréable
incroyable un comptable il est
formidable
j'ai passé mon enfance on décaisse à sa
fin mon père était cinéaste et ma mère
souffler le vert à murano
elle m'avait laissé à ma grand-mère est
logé dans un bal et à cette bonne
vieille était un peu chauve souris
j'ai gardé dans un coffret les membranes
qui relayait ses bras à s'écoute
elles sont aujourd'hui comme du
parchemin est passé pour sorcière
messieurs randonnée nocturne n'avait
d'autre but que la quête une pitance
c'est à pois quand elle me j'ai découpé
les membranes et j'ai poussé le corps
sur le toit mais où était la méfiance
même pas mademoiselle qu'elle a pris
toutes les inepties gens nous cette
petite bien changé même ton odeur ta
saveurs les ans c'est pas beau léo tu as
les cheveux longs mais j'étais dans la
peau mais j'étais dans la peau mais
jeter dans la poule 1
je ne suis pas joli joli
sam pas beaucoup bon mais contre toi moi
je grille
vous le feu à la bombe n'a peut-être pas
les bras l'athlète de ta peut-être pas
le torse velu
mais j'adore tenir est deux qui se
brouille de confier quelques semaines
burke il était une fois un jeune
concombres mais alors pas sympathique
tout il storey il tournait à l'orangé le
premier sans la plage le dernier à
partir il se gonfler les miquelots le
pédoncule provoquant les concombres s en
est elle folle il avait laissé passion
de se glisser vers vous de ce froid quai
avec ça les nervures énorme
c'était quoi la coqueluche de la plage
encouragés par les systèmes légaux
qu'elle était si mignon que tu ta
manette parts
mon dieu dit mademoiselle ce large part
falloir changer de vie marc falloir
manger dès qu'on rouvre le matin perdu
pastis colombe récurer au concombre et
du fait
elle s'adapte 1
c'est fou ce combo légumes que vous
tenez un merci mademoiselle se loge de
balle gros stock est pas couché le maire
accompagné d'un greffier dans la za
procès verbal de l'accouchement
il n'en croyait pas ses yeux
mademoiselle solange sur son lit de
souffrance était toute faille clair il
fruit d'un concombre manu
une chanson qui date de mon temps
regarde un peu c'est sa lecture
s'appelle jaber beaucoup il est aigri
leur lait slick tué tonnes j'irai sur la
loin et dribblait toof libres heureux
rl et bourgogne les versions fourbus
bourny fleix rengard jaber voc monfils à
cette gueule qui m'aura ses griffes qui
est galloise au jeu boom est récente
elle ferait mieux dans death match à
l'eau je ne rends pas oui pourquoi pas
ce moment chacun
il était une fois des x man une personne
qui était maquignons à bucarest
au moment où vous jure a fait un excès à
paris sous la plume à femmes en 1860
date l annexion de vaugirard à paris au
moment même de la signature
une habitante de malades prenez le
bateau pour bucarest où elle travaillait
depuis deux ans comme maquignons et
m'attendais près de la fontaine du
médicis au même moment un maquignon
depuis qu'un resta pourrait maquignons
orgie rien l'os installé dans la ville
depuis deux ans et qui n'en bougera plus
jusqu'à sa mort quitter manas et
m'attendais à paris sous la pluie
jusque là c'est clair non vraiment pas
quel avantage non pas beau garçon
des shows il ya de grands pieds n'a pas
pas au bail mais ça va quand à lèvres
page il parle peu plus tous ces gens là
sont des ratés je vois ça il bloque les
pompes ou bien qu'ils ont même pas
réussi à faire partir le refuge et
indique nous tout de même aux plus
jeunes gens là n'ont pas de fortune
pauvre petit
elle qui est toujours fourrée au cinéma
au début comment est on pourra venir en
vacances c'est les shadoks hors des
grandes vacances
non non ça ne va pas durer comme ça il
faut en finir cette pauvre enfant est
folle on serait obligés soit visée non
je vais donc j'évite
non ça ne se passera pas comme ça mais
non tu ne pâtira pas de ses créatures
puisque c'est comme ça je m'en vais
vivre ma vie tel qu'il est il me plaît
je me fais l'effet 7 avril
il est bancale des séries bras
m
c'est complet il est muet et qu'à quai
cette ambiance est un fait épiler
je me plais